And most of us know the
dua. Most of the Muslim know this dua.
Yes or
no? It is a verse of the Quran of Surah
Bakra chapter number two verse number
201. Oh my Lord give us the best in this
world and the Akar and save me from the
torment of hellfire. All of us know yes
or no. Okay. Do you know one verse
before
this? Now who amongst you who's not afid
Quran and knows one verse before this?
Surah Bakra chapter 2 verse number
200 raise your hand who's not aidul
Quran who's not aid Quran and
knows the verse
before surah bakar chapter 2 verse 201
that is verse number 200 who knows
that no
one person are you office are you in
Quranist
If you're half then no you don't qualify
for the test. Even my son is half
therefore he cannot raise his
hand. I told those who are not half
is it is such a it is one of the most
common dua that Muslims
do. Oh my lord give us the best in this
world and the and save us from the
torment of hellfire. The worst before
this Allah
says they are the people who pray
for when we give them we do not give
them and then the verse comes the best
of those people who
pray you pray for this world best of
this world and the hereafter and save us
from the torment of the hellfire. So it
should not only be beneficial for this
world. If your goal is only beneficial
in making money in this world only,
Allah will not give you a. What is our
goal? Jenna. What is the goal of every
Muslim? Jenna. What is the purpose of
our life? Worshiing Allah so that we go
to
Jenna. Our purpose is worshiping
Allah. What is our goal? Jenna, not dun.
But yet you can ask for
dunya. The mufaser they say in this dua
you asking for three
things. Oh my lord give us the best in
this world number one the best in aka
number two and save us from the torment
of hell number three. That means one/ird
is for this duny and 2/3 is for
a. So the mufaser say that if you ask
for dun see you ask for dunya less than
a some say maximum not more than that.
Some say maximum aka if you ask only for
dun Allah will give duny but you will
not give a in the other place in the
Quran in surah hud Allah says if you ask
for dun Allah gives you duny but not aka
if you ask for a Allah gives you a and
both so the higher level is only ask for
a duny comes in that but if you ask for
dun also you're
permitted Allah says If you ask for a
Allah gives you a and dunya both. So our
main goal should be aka even if it is
100% aka no problem. Dunya will come as
a byproduct. You know
byproduct and I'll give you examples in
the end of my talk. You do only for a
Allah will give you dunya without
fail. But if you do only for your akar
is
gone. And this dunya as compared to a is
very small. Average human being live for
about 70 75
years. Some may die early 50 years 40
years. Some may die 90 100 not more than
that
110 compared to a eternal